avec nous ce soir l'économiste clément
gignac sénateurs affiliée au groupe
progressiste du sénat bonsoir nous
sommes suppliant les sénateurs devront
se prononcer également sur la loi sur
les mesures d'urgence dans les prochains
jours une fois que ce sera passé à la
chambre des communes qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la décision du gouvernement
d'utiliser la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence pour déloger les manifestants
à ottawa mais prenez en main comme vous
savez l'ensemble des sénateurs voit bien
qu'il faut faire de quoi parce qu'on
parle plus du manifestation d'une
occupation et les sénateurs la majorité
sont indépendants donc pas de ligne de
parti cependant l'autre un précédent on
se traite maintenant aux questions
financières le fait d'intervenir là
dedans sources c'est un précédent quand
vous savez quand on évoque une loi sur
mesure chance comme sur nos maillots de
cris pas prenez en main qu une crise
nationale
l'eau donc les yeux au ciel à vos yeux
et national je vois un avocat mais c'est
pas une évidence parce que l'eau on voit
ce qui s'est passé en alberta s'est
passé je prends pas ça va on depuis avec
les lois actuelles avant même des lois
sur mesure d'urgence voir votre
opération policière la deuxième c'est
qu'il faut que en raison des lois
distante des provinces edwin ce pâté
cueillant viennent pas à bout qui doit
faire appel à ce moment là au fédéral et
c'est aussi la démonstration d'étape au
fait puisque d'enfants eu un peu on veut
dire une mauvaise gestion au niveau
local est sans doute un peu de
complaisance de la part de ce service à
votre ex préfet est ce que voudront
serono loin si ce monsieur fillion moins
quand on dit que le sac à 10h et
beaucoup qui participe même
indirectement donc si vous avez fait des
dons en argent ou si vous faites un des
dons en argent pour supporter une cause
cette fois-ci on part des ménages à ce
prêt est une autre cause et à ce moment
là pouvait être sujet allait louer leur
j'ai eu je suis un peu plus rassuré ce
soir que je les teste maintenant parce
que l'on me dit maintenant que ce même
s'il avait donné 25 ou ça en pièces le
deux semaines vous tomberez pas ce coup
de la loi c'est ce qui est depuis que
les tigres a été adopté que si le
contenu à verser de l'argent alors que
c'est vrai même une festif une
manifestation occupation noval et eu le
coup de la loi mais un peu plus rassuré
mais clairement quand on dit qu'on va
annuler où on va en fait tenu les
polices d'assurances des comptes
conjoints donc si la conjointe et reste
à vancouver son mari et à ce moment-là
ça soit le renouvellement du potet que
ce soit le compte bancaire tout est à
vous et je
comprends qu'on qu'on frappe avec les
finances l'argument c'est là on va
frapper là où ça fait mal les finances
les policiers ont quand même indiqué
avoir trouvé des armes et on parle de
groupes extrémistes qui seraient
derrière une partie des manifestants des
manifestations c'est c'est quand même
sérieux ou est-ce que c'est pas
suffisant ça pour utiliser une loi comme
celle sur les mesures d'urgence mais
c'est pour ça que moi mon idée t'as pas
fait qu'un que jouer ce genre de
nouvelles le ive des mains sales incline
appuyer les mesures que voulez vous nous
présenter tout se présentait mais entre
nous c'est pas la première fois il n'est
pas la dernière fois qu'on va voir des
groupes extrémistes qui vont s'organiser
pour renverser 28 mai gouvernement et on
eu des polices et on eu de la grc et
d'un réseau d'information qui sont là
qui va faire en sorte sinon ce que c'est
vrai monsieur fillon c'est que dans 30
jours voile renouveler puis voir
renouveler ce constat main parce que ça
va arriver l'an prochain ou dans deux
ans qu'on va faire appel à chaque fois à
cette loi parce qu'une menace qui s'en
vient
est ce que vous êtes d'avis que la
ministre sa robe trop de pouvoir sur le
plan financier mais c'est beaucoup de
pouvoirs publics seulement c'est nous on
est indépendants ont fait venir des
experts les avocats l'ailé les actions
financières pouvoir les tenants et
aboutissements parce qu'il ya des
implications pour aller avec ça mais
cette fois ci c'est impossible c'est à
prendre ou à laisser donc sans doute
qu'on va l'appuyer dans mon corps mais
clairement après 30 jours avoir un post
mortem de tout ça est ce que prévoit
d'ailleurs la louer le caire un examen
pourquoi qu'on est rendu donc je
comprends clément gignac que vous allez
si ça se rend jusqu'au sénat parce que
c'est certain que si on devait mettre
fin dans les prochaines heures et
prochains jours à la manifestation à
ottawa parce que déjà un début de
commencement d'arrestation ce soir
peut-être qu'on va arrêter les débats et
con con que le gouvernement ne
s'exposera même pas avoir sa loi ne pas
être acceptées mais si ça se rend
jusqu'au sénat vous allez dire oui et
vos collègues sénateurs parce que vous
échangez ensemble que les deux bouts en
fait pour mettre la meilleure raison si
en fait monsieur savard m'inviter
mesures peuvent rire ce roi qui le
donnait ce que des remorqueurs et ont
obligé maintenant de les remonter alors
qu'à manière de dire non ne serait ce
que pour ça c'est une bonne raison
depuis c'est très divisés au niveau du
sénat je voudrais que la majorité sont
ouverts à l'idée que force au service et
si nous est clairement démontré que ces
principes ou est là pour donner des
outils supplémentaires pour que ce
serait et en plus on voit que des
financements par type de fonds étrangers
c'est vraiment inquiétant que ce sera
appuyé par comptes afin qu'on renouvelle
après 30 jours faudra vraiment
convaincre le curieux du 2 mai et de
prolonger cette enveloppe est si loin
des locaux est ce qu'un danger avec une
loi comme celle là qui vise les comptes
bancaires qui j'ai des comptes bancaires
que des gens soient tentés de déplacer
leurs capitaux à l'extérieur du canada
ou quand je pense que c'est quand même
une minorité je crois que je vois avec
les informations du au courant de la
journée depuis qu'on s'est parlé l'offre
comprend que c'est poli de la part
qu'ils ont donné à venir jusqu'au bout
de trois jours sont visés parce c'est
vraiment une
comédie un groupe très organisé très
sophistiqué qui est usée mains des
crypto monnaie pour financer le tout
donc et la majorité de fonds venaient de
l'étranger de toute façon donc dans ce
sens là je suis rassuré mais il faudra
avoir après cela un examen de ce décret
l'eau et de le pouvoir que ce dynamisme
des finances et malheureusement dans
contextuel on ne peut pas toutes les
réponses merci clément gignac d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir oubliez pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit
oh